[Musik]
zürich ist eine stadt in bauboom das war
mitte 1980 schon einmal so dieser
bauboom bildete den rahmen und teilweise
auch die ursache der schrecklichsten
bluttat die die stadt je erlebt hat
am 16 april 1986 betritt bau polizeichef
günther nun das zürcher hochbauamt
[Musik]
er erschießt in vier büros vier seiner
engsten mitarbeiter ganz gezielt mit
kopfschüssen
[Musik]
einen fünften mann verletzte er schwer
als die polizei eintrifft ist er
verschwunden
[Musik]
welche umstände führten dazu dass
günther ja nun so brutal tötete
wieso verübte der 45 jährige architekt
diese von außen gesehen absolut
kaltblütige tat
[Musik]
chernomaz opfer waren nicht nur die
getöteten opfer waren auch die
zurückbleibenden eltern witwen und
mehrere minderjährige kinder
das offizielle zürich traut
beklemmender schmerz
tiefe trauer
und schwer lastende sorge erfüllen uns
seiten eintreffen dieser unglaublichen
nachricht und werden uns nie wieder
verlassen doch in der stadt im bauboom
trifft der täter auf erstaunlich viel
verständnis auf einer mauer steht der
fürchterliche satz ja nun hatte recht
leserbriefschreiber meinen endlich hat
einmal eine richtig aufgerollt ich war
auch schon mal daran zu schießen
hoffentlich war das meinen chef ich
würde am liebsten jeden morgen mit der
pistole durch das büro rennen
zwei jahre nach der tat kommt das
blutbad im bauamt vor das zürcher
obergericht in diesen jahren heißen
konflikte am arbeitsplatz kanonisierung
das wort mobbing ist noch nicht erfunden
das medieninteresse ist riesig und
viele prozessbesucher identifizieren
sich schon fast mit der tat
was
ich bin
[Musik]
für
meine tochter machen es passiere
nein das wäre
für die angehörigen ist das halt im
schlimmsten fall passieren oder wenn sie
ihre liebste verlieren dürfen so eine
dramatische art und danach die runde die
pressen der öffentlichkeit mit sie
gehöre dass einige selbstverständnis
viele tage verhandeln ist das ist
absolut inakzeptabel dass nur
psychoanalytische es hat mit denen
nordteil von selbst aber einfach so
schmidt zum zug kommt wo man schlicht
sagen natürlich äußerst aggressivität
und ein ende das so viel es vorlebt und
zwar
mit großer furore autor leitet das mit
still und leise gemacht da haben sich
sogar damit identifizieren
staatsanwalt marcel bärtschi wird auf
mord und lebenslänglichem zuchthaus
plädieren er sieht die tat als
eigentliche hinrichtung
verteidiger bernhard gehrig wird sich
für eine strafe von unter zehn jahren
zuchthaus einsetzen für ihn handelt ja
nun in einer extremen ausnahmesituation
vor den richtern sitzt ein unauffälliger
mensch zu beginn werden einige
besonderheiten seiner lebensgeschichte
herausgearbeitet
ja nun wächst in österreich auf sein
vater wurde im krieg erschossen zu
seiner jugend im jesuitischen internat
sagt er
positiv war dass geistig fördernde klima
negativ der stark männliche patriarchats
er heiratet eine schweizerin und
eröffnet in bern ein architekturbüro das
büro läuft schlecht seiner ehe scheitert
er verliebt sich neu beim tanzen das
unglück beginnt
drei jahre vor der tat kaufte er einen
revolver um sich vor dem ehemann der
freundin zu schützen mit dieser waffe
wird er später das blutbad im amt
anrichten
zwei jahre vor der tat bekommt er im
zürcher amtshaus die stelle als
polizeichef und zieht in eine wohnung
direkt nebenan das wird sich als
verhängnisvoll erweisen
zürich baut in dieser zeit wie wild
viele riesenprojekte brauchen
ausnahmebewilligung von allen seiten der
druck ausgeübt
es geht um wirtschaftliche interessen
und um sehr viel geld
im zürcher hochbauamt herrscht ja nun
stellenantritt personalstopp obwohl
arbeit und pendenzen sich häufen
[Musik]
kennys vorgänger hatte völlig überlastet
und gesundheitlich angeschlagen
gekündigt
eine interne reorganisation bringt zudem
unruhe ins amt
für die schlechte stimmung
verantwortlich machen viele den
politischen chef stadtrat hugo fahrer
[Musik]
viele sagen später legales arbeiten sei
unter ihm nicht mehr möglich gewesen
in dieses chaos kommt der neue
unerfahrene polizeichef schon
es ist klar so
eine person nie hat der fachstelle für
die funktion und ziehen auch der
praktische
situation wo sie
völlig im lagerung standen
ist natürlich die konstellation war
politisch inszeniert hat den norden
glücklich sondern im nachhinein
kommentar sehr gut gestartet wie sie mit
schuld
strafrechtsprofessor christian
schwarzenegger hat den fall genau
studiert gibt es so etwas wie eine
übergeordnete schuld der behörden
strafrechtlich ist ein ganz komplexe
gefüge verursachen mit ursache einer
sporthose und zwar geht es darum wer hat
tötet wer hat gegen strafrechtliche
normen stoße und das ist da eindeutig
der ja nun das ist das thema von
strafverfahren junkers strafrecht nie
absolut die gerechtigkeit hersteller und
alle verantwortlichkeiten und mit
ursachen und so weiter die fangen
sondern als fokussiert auf das
individuum und stellt eine schuld fest
alles andere was über andere mechanismen
empfangen werden und die gibt es gibt
politische verantwortlichkeit nach an
politische entscheidungsträger
abwählen es gibt auch möglichkeit
innerhalb der verwaltung
disziplinarverfahren für ordnung sorgen
aber das sind immer nur teilaspekte
die gesamt die problematik kameras mit
dem recht gar nicht richtig erfassen
die politischen konsequenzen werden in
der stadt im bauboom folgen leider viel
zu spät
eine parlamentarische
untersuchungskommission stellt
abstimmungs manipulationen von stadtrat
fahrer fest sie kommt damals noch nicht
auf die idee auch seine amtsführung zu
kritisieren
ganz anders im gerichtssaal dort werfen
die richter den stadtbehörden die wahl
günther kann uns explizit vor er sei für
diese stelle denkbar ungeeignet gewesen
staatsanwalt bärtschi erklärt schon
frühere arbeitgeber hätten ihn als
kompliziert und perfektionistisch
bezeichnet
anwalt gehrig betont was viele im amt
bestätigten dass ein mensch allein die
viele arbeit gar nicht bewältigen konnte
ja nun selbst sagt am prozess die ganze
misere die tausende von hängigen
baugesuchen war mir bei meinem
amtsantritt nicht bekannt
nun macht von anfang an massenhaft
überstunden und bewegt sich nur noch
zwischen dem amt seiner wohnung und dem
nahe gelegenen café
ein fataler teufelskreis
weil ich immer nach höchsten
und dieses hier doch nervös
nervös stellen der fc dem stelle stark
anzieht und da hat er sehr oft nicht
fertig gast hätte ich springen ist
grafisch sehr oft hat er das asse mit
platz 37 der seite der rebellen sitzen
muss wieder weg und
man hat sich dann wie zuletzt runkel
villmar begrüßte dass der chef ist von
der polizei habe dachte ich das ist
schon das muss man so nüchtern
zu darum kümmert doch die nervosität ist
einmalig sie will
[Musik]
die situation im amts wird immer
schwieriger mehr als ein jahr vor der
tat bleiben baugesuche liegen wichtige
kontrollarbeiten werden nicht mehr
gemacht
fristüberschreitungen kosten die
bauwirtschaft millionen
[Musik]
niemand im baupolizei team wollte
deshalb den chefposten bevor nun kam
über ihn sagten sie damals er hatte von
anfang an keine chance
statt einem rettungsring darf man ihn
steine nach
sie ließen ihn in der luft hängen
einige der späteren opfer beschweren
sich bei jones' vorgesetzten seine
probezeit wird verlängert
die reorganisations firma heiq nimmt die
veralteten strukturen der baupolizei
unter die lupe
die spannungen im amt steigen weiter
jennings mitarbeiter verlieren die
geduld gegenüber dem chef
wahnsinnig kompliziert
unfähig und inkompetent
die pumpe muss weg
ein jahr vor der tat ist ja nun im amt
völlig isoliert
verharrt damit gerät der ich denn ein
anderer platz gegangen haben andere
seite vom café er rät sich für sich und
ist sucht es ist schon gefallen hat wie
die andere zum landkreis sind und sie
biete ich eine chance für sich als sie
person entdeckt die ihr könnt jetzt
zusammen oder das ist versetzt der
selbst in der partie sind einfach mit
für sich see und im saarland mit care
bietet am prozess wird bekannt dass ich
zu dieser zeit endlich die
geschäftsprüfungskommission des
gemeinderates mit den schwierigkeiten
des polizeichefs befasste ja nun schrieb
schon zu dieser zeit ich habe damals
unüberhörbar notsignale gesendet
korrosion und überbeanspruchung führen
auch beim menschen zum material bruch
und ein mitglied der kommission sagte ja
nun war schon damals völlig nervös und
gestresst mir fielen seine ab gekauften
fingernägel auf
ebenfalls am prozess wird betont dass
schon damals eine mitarbeiter der
reorganisations firma hayek das
verhalten chinas auf er war überfordert
und führungs unfähig er kam mir schon
damals als selbstmordkandidat vor
channels persönliche lebenssituation
spitzt sich in dieser zeit weiter zu
seine freundin die kurz zuvor bei ihm
eingezogen ist zieht wieder aus die
trennung von seiner frau wird
rechtskräftig
sieben monate vor der tat ist der tag
und nacht im amt anzutreffen
menschlichen kontakt hat er fast nur
noch mit dem abfahrt
ja ich habe von den slot eine damals
halt auch mal die arbeit unterbrechen
und dani pedrosa
und
das haben wir mit freuden eigentlich
zurück
wenn man etwas wie richer den okavango
orden und das bestätigt das einfach
meine problem kommentiert von einem
komischen rufen und
aber da sagt er hinter san cristobal
huet et cetera
ganz beruhigend
will zusammen und
die habenseite menge
empfindlicher haut können sodann runde
wird am allerufer neben versuchen eines
sprechgesangs
einfach dass da bin ich und so bin ich
stark sie und schlussendlich an
iranischen am morgen 27 experten den
laufschuhen
wahrscheinlich ertrunken
im amt ist die miese stimmung auf dem
höhepunkt einem späteren opfer gibt ja
nur büro verbot ein anderer sucht sich
eine neue stelle die er aus familiären
gründen nicht antritt
immer häufiger tönt aus den büros die
pumpe muss weg die spur muss wenn du
musik musik musik
radweg gefahren oder flügel richard und
die rangnick
erzwungenen acht mittagspause am gericht
rund um den fall scheinen nichts
außergewöhnliches mord und
bombendrohungen häuften sich in dieser
zeit die tat wurde zum katalysator für
eigene gewaltfantasien
der gerichtspräsident betont dass der
bau polizeichef fünf monate vor der tat
in einer einzigen woche 86 stunden
arbeitete und alles persönliche liegen
ließ gegenüber seiner freundin sprach
günther nun damals von selbstmord bei
dem er noch ein paar leute mitnehmen
werde
wieso war er nicht fähig einfach
auszusteigen
die wahrscheinlichen ganzen große
soziale druck k
das ist offensichtlich ein job sicher
ins wo immer soziale sicherheit und der
finanzielle sicherheit und einfachheit
weil man aufs spiel setze das ist ein
total spiels setzte das ist das kann man
nicht nachvollziehen das ist
völlig
widersinnig diese sind muss also ich
meine das ist manchmal sehr sensibel
sind und wo messi nie viele und einem ic
hat überhaupt nicht mehr wirklich wagner
hat sondern not reagiert hat mit kommt
mit aggressivität und je meter sonst
gemacht hat desto weniger ist ja auch
und hat das aber nicht verstanden warum
hat er gar nicht
rosmarie welter hat günter csar nun
dreieinhalb monate vor der tat an einer
silvesterfeier kennengelernt
er kommt allein wirkt einsam nervös
trotzdem entwickeln sich gute gespräche
er erzählt von 660 überstunden in einem
jahr von monaten fast ohne schlaf
er wirkt aber auch charmant und
geistreich je länger desto gelöster
doch kein festteilnehmer getraut sich
hilfe anzubieten genauer zu fragen
günther ja nun verlässt das fest allein
die christ dass es miserabel gab die hat
eigentlich er landete in retz ethischen
klinik mit dem sogenannten er versammelt
bruch ich hatte gehofft dass es macht
hier ist depressiv sie und haben aber
nicht könne
ohne kohle umbringen
[Musik]
die konflikte im bauamt eskalieren in
den folgenden monaten weiter zwei der
späteren opfer charles gehörende
arbeitsgruppe an die das amt total
reorganisiert sie stehen ihm sehr
kritisch gegenüber
er ist unehrlich
er hat keine autorität
er ist völlig unfähig
zu hören sind aber auch bemerkungen wie
es war ein richtiges kesseltreiben gegen
ihn sie trieben ihn wie einen hund in
die ecke
vor gericht erzählt sein anwalt das
könnte ja nun in dieser zeit in ein
tiefes loch wie
der gerichtspsychiater spricht von einer
erschöpfungsdepression von einem sich
aufbauenden tat affekt
ganz anders der staatsanwalt er sieht im
charakter des angeklagten indizien für
die spätere tat er bezeichnet ihn als
über pedantisch und unfähig eigene
fehler zuzugeben
prozesspause
was für einen eindruck hat günter ja nun
bei den gerichts besuchern hinterlassen
sie dann für 13 real kommentar zion von
einem effektiven notstand im bezirk
weil ich mich nicht ganz überzeugt
mit dem totschlagen weg grundsätzlich
hast du das argument die serie im moment
nicht schwer krank gesicht das klappt
bleibe ich nicht
immer intelligenter
den trägern traum ist auch eine
das ist die zeit da hatte ich eine
richtige stadt schotten hatten
der prozess geht weiter der protest eher
indirekt auch der stadt zürich gilt und
stadtrat udo vorne sechs wochen vor der
tat sind wahlen er wird nicht mehr
gewählt nicht zuletzt aufgrund der
schwierigkeiten und
kostenüberschreitungen im bauamt von der
neuen stadträten wird hartes
durchgreifen erwartet
der draht des anzeiger züri woche bringt
sechs tage vor der tat das fass zum
überlaufen
in einem artikel wird gemutmaßt wer wohl
von farmers nachfolgerin der köchin
ursula koch zuerst in die pfanne gehauen
werde besonders schonend wird als
unfähig dargestellt er sieht sich als
mensch und fachmann total entwertet
bei einigen personen im bauamt soll der
artikel genugtuung ausgelöst haben zwei
der späteren opfer fordern bei ihren
vorgesetzten jones absetzung
einen tag vor der tat trifft sich die
haie organisationsgruppe
dabei sind drei der späteren opfer ja
nun wird scharf kritisiert
obwohl ihn die haie leute freundlich
gegenüber stehen sieht er sich nur noch
von feinden umgeben
einer der dabei war sagt kein chef mit
autorität hätte sich so behandeln dass
ja nun sieht nach eigenen aussagen nicht
mehr klar er räumt sein büro und
verabschiedet sich mit dank von einigen
mitarbeitern
den abend vor der tat verbringt er
allein zu hause er der sonst nur mäßig
trinkt lehrt eine ganze flasche wein er
sieht seine ganze existenz infrage
gestellt den verlust seiner stelle den
zusammenbruch seiner ehe
er will weg aber was er tun will ist im
laut späteren aussagen vor gericht
unklar
er bestreitet auch damals die tat schon
geplant zu haben er zählt nur von einer
großen inneren leere
am frühen morgen sitzt könnte ja nun im
café vis á vis vom amt er hat bereits
ein testament gemacht ein aktenkoffer
schon gepackt und seinem stellvertreter
einen abschiedsbrief geschrieben
die ihm bedienende serviertochter er war
völlig verwirrt und verabschiedete sich
als wenn es für immer werden zwei mal
sagt sie
tun sie um gottes willen nichts dummes
dann betritt günter thum das amt laut
gerichtspsychiater in einem akut
depressiven verzweiflungs zustand
[Musik]
doch völlig gezielt tötet er mit einem
kopfschuss den kreis architekten max
fischer
[Musik]
genau so gezielt erschießt er dem kreis
architekten herbert nec
er geht mit der waffe in der tasche zum
lift
im vierten stock schießt er wieder mit
einem kopfschuss den juristen stefan
gang
im büro des juristen kam matthias
toggweiler schießt er zweimal bis dieser
tödlich getroffen ist
dann muss er nach laden
als abteilungs sekretär bergmann im gang
auftaucht schießt ja nun wieder
das vsg bitterer tag gleicht also im
wachstum geben wird es figuren
und intel was ist denn da und dort daher
der name
behaupten
denn
unmittelbar
kommunen sondern der vorfälle der hand
von dr jetzt
wird man überlebt wie durch ein wunder
und er holt sie später wieder von seinen
verletzungen
als die polizei eintrifft ist scheinen
spurlos verschwunden
später wird bekannt dass er noch am
gleichen tag innsbruck und flüchtete
aber das war dort davon mitgezogen hat
günter annen hat vier menschen brutal
getötet es waren keine amok schütze er
hat auf die personen gezielt von denen
er sich am schwersten bedroht fühlte er
hat nicht nur ihr leben ausgelöscht
sondern auch das leben der angehörigen
der eltern frauen kinder für immer
verändert
erst nach dreiwöchiger fahndung wird er
in frankreich verhaftet er war leicht zu
finden denn er schrieb seiner freundin
von dort einen brief mit
selbstmordabsichten
vor gericht sagt er später
rückblickend ist mir die tat
unbegreiflich ich kann nur sagen dass
ich es zutiefst bedauere im februar 1988
verurteilen die richter günter csar nun
wegen vorsätzlicher tötung zu 17 jahren
zuchthaus
das gericht spricht von einer
kaltblütigen massentötung es anerkennt
aber auch eine extremsituation
und es stellt sogar fest dass jen und
seelische zwangslage von seinen opfern
mit verschuldet wurde das von der
staatsanwaltschaft angerufene
bundesgericht folgt diese argumentation
nicht es weist das obergericht anja nun
wegen fortgesetzten mordes zu
verurteilen
dieses verschärft zwei jahre nach dem
ersten prozess die strafe auf 20 jahre
zuchthaus
das gutachten des gerichtspsychiaters
das praktisch ausschließt dass jan o je
wieder so etwas tun würde wird nicht
mehr berücksichtigt
liberale juristen empfinden das neue
urteil als sehr hart ja also eigentlich
hätte ja nun gerade keine fehler will
experte hat festhalte dass er gefährlich
ist und damit verbindet sich fragt was
wollen damit strasser was soll's
strafrecht und die für die genannt
wurden sind eigentlich sehr auf
zukunftsgerichtete
integriere gesellschaften an bord sind
problemlöser jetzt sieht man ja nun
eigentlich gar nicht dass dafür eine
maske sieht das eher strenger bestraft
ich finde also für mich gab sonne kann
überhaupt nur dann absolute höchststrafe
das wären sie nie mehr in sachen
ja noch heute war das praktische war
aber ich weiß es wird verwarnt
regelungsgehalt
es gibt zwei die fragestellung wurde
abschreckungswirkung betrifft würde
trittin ähnliche situation natur harte
strafe abgeschreckt werde es ist eine
sehr realistische sollen ähnliche
konstellationen sich überhaupt
vorstellen
und drumrum rein ruft die grundfrage
zurück ich dann halt irgendwie neu bis
anders mit dem strafrecht verbunden
nämlich dass abreagieren veröffentlich
emotionen dass das erschreckt sie und
das entsetzt sie und dass man das
erkannt tolerieren und das ist ein
wichtiger faktor
wo man mit einer modernen strafrecht
eigentlich nicht direkt wort verbinde wo
man aber vielleicht aus dem strafrecht
unser bringt will der gesellschaft
seines bedürfnis hat und das deckt sich
teil wie es mindestens meter neueren
hirnforschung
zeigt dass manche frau und empfinde wenn
sie andere bestraft obwohl sie kein
nutzer der vorhand und das zeigt eben
dass im kern vom strafrecht vielleicht
auch nicht so rational
praktisch
günter thon hat knapp 14 jahre
abgesessen bevor er anfang 2000 auf
bewährung freigelassen wird
er lernte im knast gärtnern und blumen
binden und der galt als modell gefangen
viele sahen ihn aber auch als genauso
kompliziert und detailversessen wie ihn
der staatsanwalt vor gericht schilderte
in zürich wird heute gebaut wie wild
noch mehr als zu zeiten der
schrecklichen bluttat
baugesetze normen und vorschriften sind
mindestens so kompliziert wie damals
unzählige kleine und vor allem riesige
großbaustellen fordern das hochbauamt
und die dort beschäftigten aufs äußerste
[Musik]
doch im amt hat sich vieles verändert
die sichtbare renovation war nicht nur
äußerlich eine klare führungsstruktur
und mehr stellen halfen die pendenzen
abzubauen nach der tat sorgte die neue
stadträtin für ordnung und einen anderen
umgangston im amt
[Musik]
seither hat die politische führung im
amt schon zweimal gewechselt je nach
amtsvorsteher ging es oft sehr hektisch
zu und
[Musik]
später dann wieder ruhiger
nur wenige die die tat damals erlebt
haben sind noch dabei doch einer damals
ein junger kreis architekt übt heute die
funktion schon uns aus auch wenn der job
jetzt an das heißt also für mitglieder
stellung hat schon nun will der kann
ohne die stärken warten und ausgeschöpft
hat sein können für mich als nachfolger
für sein vorgänger und ich nur sagen
natürlich mein handy zwischen ressourcen
überholen könnte ganze abteilungen
strukturieren und organisieren
und sachsen dienstabteilung wo
mitte mai noch sehr gut funktioniert
und trotz der hohen belastung
einige sehr gutes betriebsklima
ziemlich sicher dass so etwas nie
passiert aber ich glaube dass
die rote farbe die zur zeit der tat auf
das zürcher stadtmodell im bauamt
gesprengt wurde ist längst verschwunden
doch in den köpfen derjenigen die die
tat miterlebten ist das blutbad im amt
nach wie vor präsent
während der fünf jahre der bedingten
entlassung war es könnte ja nun verboten
sich in der innenstadt aufzuhalten als
er trotzdem in der nähe des amts gesehen
wurde verursachte das große angst und
aufregung
er lebt jetzt außerhalb der stadt zürich
mit neuem namen und der freundin von
damals
angst hatten auch einige der angehörigen
der opfer als günter csar nun vor
sechseinhalb jahren entlassen wurde doch
er hat seit hier bewiesen dass er nicht
mehr gefährlich ist
trotzdem die angehörigen können die tat
nicht vergessen ihre botschaften an die
einwohner der stadt dem bauboom die
einst so viel verständnis für die tat
auf brachten
die schlimmste trauer geht vorbei aber
so wie damals kann es nie mehr werden
wenn ich darüber rede tut es weh wenn es
gestern gewesen wäre
wir sind immer noch sehr angeschlagen
aber der mörder steht in der hand gottes
wie wir auch ich habe mein leben
geändert und mich viel intensiver mit
leben und sterben befasst
könnte ähnliches wieder geschehen in
dieser stadt und anderswo
erst vor zwei jahren erschoss in zürich
ein angestellter der kantonalbank seine
beiden chefs und sich selbst schon
vorher gab es in der schweiz mehrere
ähnliche fälle die bluttat könnte jones
aber blieb bis heute bei weitem das
brutalste tötungsdelikt am arbeitsplatz
um
2% und ich schickte aus und therapie da
will ich ein bessers sensorium häufiger
als vor 20 jahren das heißt die
gesellschaftliche prämisse sind
und ich meine dass das thema bio witz
gemacht werden über
sobald das ist viel energie das ist ein
stoff der ht türkei
persönlichkeit ich nur aus jux amt und
das finde ich gut
das blutbad im bauamt sollte ein mahnmal
bleiben
[Musik]
für alle die aus einer aussichtslosen
situation nicht aussteigen können und
für alle die etwas kommen sehen und
nicht einzuschreiten waren
[Musik]